[Musique]
le rêve de marianne semble toussaint
trouver une adolescente qui s'occupera
de sa mignonne petite fille quelques
heures par semaine
je moi ce que je voyais ce un blog dès
4h samedi exemple un bêta midi pour
commencer par connaissance avec mon bébé
créer une relation parce qu est ce que
je voulais c'est le gardien qui suivent
en temps les vols sont mon enfant il
aimerait avoir un peu de temps pour
faire des tâches dans la maison ou pour
se reposer je me disais si j'y présente
sur place je devrais avoir encore plus
un bassin de plus large parce que la
responsabilité est moins grand puis
j'étais prêt à faire le trou verront
plus pourtant elle est prête à payer
jusqu'à 15 $ de l'heure c'est en 16 et
18 dollars de l'heure sans reçus moi je
trouvais qu'elle 15 valeurs dollars
c'est tout à fait raisonnable au delà de
15 $ dollars je trouve ça voudrait
mabuse et surtout dans la mesure que ces
séances il la table elle a publié des
annonces dans une demi-douzaine de
groupes facebook avec une seule
condition aucun cellulaire pendant le
gardiennage on me disait que le jeune
était réfractaire à venir s'ils ne
pouvaient pas employer son téléphone
cellulaire sur le lieu de garde et que
c'était à moi de changer ma perception
des choses
et l'on parle d'un bel x1 pas encore
tous eu lieu à 6 il ya le manuel
gardiens avertis avec la pandémie le
nombre de jeunes qui suit le cours
gardiens avertis et passer au québec de
40 lille à 30 milles par annie
facilement 30 % des participants qui
sont déjà attendus parce qu'il ya des
amis de la famille des voisins qui
attendent qu'ils aient leur certificat
de participation ça peut être comme cool
des couleurs et les parents doivent bien
les payer pour profiter de leur service
une sont habitués à 5 sauf que 5 c il ya
25 30 ans étaient cinq la formatrice
suggère aux jeunes de demander entre 7
et 15 $ de l'heure ça s'approche du
salaire minimum parce que de la pénurie
de main d'oeuvre le fait qu'on va
chercher les jeunes beaucoup plus tôt
pour aller travailler au dépanneur ou
dans un restaurant un rapide vous voyez
le trait au milieu les familles
devraient selon elle donner au moins du
dollar de l'heure et c'est une
reconnaissance et une stimulation pour
les avoir comme plus sérieux dans le
gardiennage plus longtemps
annie elle l'a trouvé sa perle rare
grâce à elisabeth la maman peut sortir
quelques heures et souffrit un peu je
saurai falip suis allé au dollar à mort
ces années la tribune de l'art amorce et
comme par les jeux olympiques
allociné mot mange au restaurant c'est
des choses banales que tout le monde
devrait avoir la jeune fille a commencé
à garder des enfants il ya déjà quatre
ans quand elle avait 12 ans s'est passé
là ça dégage de l'énergie ceate c'est le
fun c'est vraiment flexible qui peut
s'arranger avec les parents ils
comprennent aussi les besoins puis sert
quinzaine elle s'était tu peux
rencontrer plein de gens elle demande
normalement 10 ou 12 dollars de l'heure
en a beaucoup qui offre plus 15 $ de
l'heure ça dépend aussi de leurs besoins
souvent c'est vraiment juste pour la
garde des enfants et à leurs serrures
qui demandent de faire du ménage la
vaisselle ou d'autres choses faye
l'europe dans les affaires ils veulent
vraiment nous garder le thé et ses
services sont très en demande j'ai pas
fait d'annoncé j'en fais pas ça sert à
rien parce que votre message c'est
vraiment lui ce bouche-à-oreille parce
que ça peut me demande des fois
d'ailleurs année se trouve très
chanceuse qu'elisabeth soit la fille
d'une amie c'est ce qui lui a permis de
la rencontrer elle tellement
exceptionnel que j'ai demandé d'être la
marraine du bébé
oui j'ai vraiment là il est à bercy est
en aura nettement le 10 comme gagnant
millions de dollars de la voix
marianne de son côté continue d'espérer
moi ce que j'aimerais trouver c'est une
gardienne qui veut créer une relation
avec ma fille sur une longue période
petite mary poppins des temps modernes
c'est marie claude morin radio canada
montréal